[Music]
i have a story
of this guy who just could not
get the hint no i'm just kidding he
wasn't even hit so he got
fired and he thought you know what i'm
gonna screw this company up
oh no and they're gonna have to rehire
me to fix it so he
thought he could give himself some type
of like job security but
that's why he got [ __ ] fired you
shady ass fool
yeah so i like the idea though maybe he
was thinking of like those cia
movies you know where they're like oh
this guy he's actually really good we
need to hire him back
yeah bring jackson back everything's
falling apart call jackson
yeah yeah oh well he's an i.t specialist
so maybe along the lines of all that
computer guys what do you call those
people that
sabotage [ __ ] so they could come in and
rescue the whole yeah like the nurses
that
that kill the be or they like
make the babies sick because they're
trying to save them but they end up
killing
or like eminem eminem it's my sing yeah
that's a thing isn't that just called
evil
no it's a thing no it's a it's a
something syndrome
yes because like they like to go oh you
seek
oh let me let me help you oh it's called
the alley-oop syndrome
because you set it up for yourself it's
ally hoop syndrome
you're like you set it up in your own
dunks i don't know
they want to toot their own they want to
toot their own horn well anyway that is
the thing i'm trying to google it can't
find it really quick a lot of people do
that though
yeah they go oh i'm here for the rescue
remember that japanese guy that would
[ __ ] pop the tires
oh excuse me ma'am oh yeah i noticed
that your tires
[ __ ] up i just so happen to have the
exact one for the make and model of your
car
can i help you oh thank you so much oh
it wasn't a hero thing it was like a
sales thing
no he just did it he could get off on
the girl saying thank you
oh okay guys he didn't even get dates or
anything it was just like
that interaction was enough for him the
pride of japan thousands
like a thousand times or something right
yeah what a legend
dude when it comes to level of uh
incellism i think japan always wins good
job very i'm very proud
and he has a pet he has that japanese
commitment too he did a thousand times
yeah
yeah because there's got to be some sort
of haiku out there where it's like you
know to do
one thing a thousand times brings peace
to the warriors spirit or something oh
we'll get your
get you laid yeah that one yeah get your
katana sheath it's like
oh that's what american sims are doing
let me top that
with the japanese warrior spirit yeah
well this dude
oh because i i was talking to byron
recently and he was telling me about the
different like
cafes and [ __ ] over there and it
definitely supports
that culture of insulin over there
because there's like
grope themed cafes and what would it be
like it'll be like
you know the the waitress doesn't come
over and stuff and talking to you and
then the lights will turn off for like
five minutes and you start to grope them
for five minutes ew
and i turned back on it's like oh what
happened what it happened like every 15
minutes or some [ __ ] like that what the
[ __ ]
i'm like that's crazy honestly honestly
i'm not talking about the after part of
it but just their brainstorm process
is very creative it's part of the theme
yeah you pay like by the hour can you
imagine the guy said you know to be dope
if imagine you go to a cafe
and then the the the server comes up to
you and then the lights like there's a
there's an outage
and you can touch them they're like
that's [ __ ] genius imagine the hiring
process
for like the waitresses i know are you
scared of the dark man
uh what are your thoughts on being
groped every five minutes
um that's a better question
yeah are you afraid of the dark i know
maybe it's the other way around so it's
protected it's like once the lights turn
off like they have to grow up as much as
possible and run around it's like a
growth buffet
yeah the waitresses oh that'd be better
yeah that would be funny though either
or be groped she was fun she was okay
with being groped but she was terrified
of the
so that is that invalid yeah
anyway back to the story so this indian
software engineer
was arrested after he got caught because
what he did is he hacked his former
employee
and deleted very important information
he deleted
a billing information of around 300 000
patients
and made around 22 000 false entries
and deleted 18 000
data entries of of patients as well what
a [ __ ] bag
that's hella patience to do that it is
[Laughter]
it was just a larger number i'll just
surprised by the watchtower
yeah i did both yeah i didn't get the
other one
oh the other okay got it it's a
complicated show you guys
it's a complicated joke
that's gave a [ __ ] nobody else gave a
[ __ ] yeah
let me just highlight the fact that
nobody gave a [ __ ] just so we could
spend with i
i just missed everything that happened
that's fair that's valid he was thinking
about the grope cafe still
yeah that's a genius business model how
do we bring that to america
started thinking if you remove the
waitress out of it then the guys would
be groping
each other in the dark and that makes
him smile that's kind of funny
but i was just thinking about how good
this sandwich is oh the one that you're
and i've been savoring it yeah
speaking of the sandwich so like i said
he did get caught because oh they
they ended up tracking the ip address
once they realized that there was some
sort of
uh breach a breach in the data data
breach
and that's how they were able to catch
up i'm like dude you're this smart but
you couldn't
you couldn't like use a vpn or something
like cover like hide your tracks
is there uh so there's an ip blocker but
are there ip blocker blockers what does
that mean
oh to unblock it maybe if there's a
registered vpn they might be going into
like
ipfinders yeah like ipfinder there is
right
it depends on what route you do to like
mask yourself
because i feel like if you it what do we
know nelson well because it's like
browsers
made for this right like onion browser
you can like what the hell is that so
like if you go to the website it'll
bounce
your signal to like 10 other computers
oh sick
but like to get to you they have to like
go through multiple is that fbi
proof though you know i mean i feel like
there's like consumers that's what you
used to like if you want to do dark web
[ __ ]
what how do you know about this what are
you buying he's buying what's happening
i mean i didn't try the dark web i tried
the browser i was curious
i was curious the level of the the
packing that i go
to is opened up an incognito window
same as far as it goes for me as well my
heart's racing
for the porno
please don't judge me why would you
watch incognito with porn what if you
want to go back to that one
favorite one that you had the day before
yeah what are you doing
that is a good point see you never have
that when you just
when you're craving that one video and
you're like oh who was that again
uh russian threesome no that's not it
that's not that's it's because you're
just conditioned to hide your tracks
you don't want to store your porn
cookies since like since like you're
like
12 years old though you always knew like
you had to do things in a way you know
as things were digitizing and you had to
figure out your quick fix to delete
stuff i feel like that was ingrained in
you
you know to the but you still got to
adapt with the tech at the time so when
incognito mode is introduced i was like
man yeah i need it complicated stuff
that's why you gotta go incognito and
then make an account and you can just
favorite it
see i don't even know what the hell
that's gonna count every website you can
make an account
there's a workaround joe make an account
i'm gonna i just got tired
of hiding my true self good for you so
we just started buying the memberships
to all the porn sites it's like your
full name social security number is your
id
and his picture he uploads well my true
self is cheap
so i never actually went that far and if
i did
i would get the trial service for like
one dollar
and then i would cancel i'm very
disciplined i would get as much
jacking off as i could for that month
offer and i'd be like cancel
damn yeah it's really efficient if you
battle me
like and you tell me like which one is
more important [ __ ] or money
hands down money because pussy's always
for free
you could jack off to it that's what i'm
saying oh okay okay
good good good well yeah the real [ __ ]
is too but then like there's a cost that
comes along with it
what's the cost pain they're an hourly
cost or an emotional cost emote yeah
something
yup but now with streaming sites
it's free okay for the phone service
yeah i mean
usually no one can [ __ ] you as good as
you can [ __ ] yourself right so
might as well just watch i think that's
only true for women ah because for guys
i think a mouth or or vagina is way
better
than my own hand i think that's why
we're so like
i need to guess some pose and that's why
the world is in balance because if it
wasn't
guys would be like i got my vibrator
[ __ ]
or whatever you know like if there was
some vibrator equivalent
where you could stick your dick into it
and it's like
way better than a woman if a fleshlight
or any of those things were better
than a than an actual woman we're gone
men and women's gonna kill all women
that's what like the the advancements of
those like cyber porn bot things in like
asia are about though right like really
trying to
get that experience unlocked right it's
not asia
it's japan thank you very much yeah get
it right dude i apologize
just japan i don't know any other asians
that's as perverted
it's true so they're not gonna come up
with the technology
they might use it but i don't know man
we gotta give props where props is due
this is true real recognize real japan
give it to japan japan
damn horn dogs did you know that um
it is a government service in japan to
get
hand jobs if you can't jack yourself off
how do you have to like prove is it kind
of like the weed test you know medical
marijuana cards
where if you just have a headache or
you're like oh
i have back pain and then you get a no
it's for people who are like
um like purple like not paraplegic
because they could
they can't they could feel like war vets
yeah they
they can't like guys that are like they
can't touch
themselves there's no way where they can
relieve themselves
there's a uh a lady a nurse a medical
professional a medical professional goes
to your house
goes to your postmates and gives you a
hand job
what
that would be funny if they're in a hot
nurse's outfit no they're just but
they're
that's under they look like grandmas
though grandmas older
probably you got to be real it's not
going to be like a fine ass trick every
time
no no have you seen asian airlines
old old ladies don't keep the jobs there
that long that's true that's true
they're gone but then old ladies in asia
still look young too like and then
grandmas are retired so
old ladies in asia are still doing
strong massages
that's what you graduate to yeah is that
kind of the jerk off
hands that you i don't know i'm just
saying like when you go to like massage
places in asia there's
often times like older women that are
like very skilled
and you know because it like their skin
is so like moistened because of the oils
that they always use
you're like wow you're experienced so
their fingers are so thick
yeah they have like muscles on their
fingers i don't
think i've ever been to like a massage
parlor where i looked at the person in
the masseuse
well sometimes it's guys too because
they're very firm but well i was like
man this is a
really attractive woman i've never said
that once
me neither what really into a massage
party yeah
not one time i try not to look at them
in the eyes why
i don't want a connection don't they
usually put the thing over because they
don't want that connection either
no like when you're you know when they
flip you over toward the end and then
you're just kind of like
there yeah and then um
they [ __ ] massage your head you know
they're massaging your head they look
down
well yeah you're not supposed to he like
i did it before
and then i saw straight into them and i
was like okay i'm gonna close my eyes
now
and then they're like you [ __ ]
they're just like dang i almost had a
[Music]
connection
[Music]
you